sens d'abord j'arrête l'hypocrisie qui
consiste à refuser de voir que c'est le
modèle économique fondé sur le libre
échange qui est responsable d'une grande
partie de l'émission des gaz à effet de
serre en france 50% d'ailleurs donc on
ne peut pas sérieusement dire qu'on va
s'attaquer à ce problème en refusant de
regarder que c'est les importations qui
représentent 50% de ces gaz à effet de
serre c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que le modèle économique fondé sur
le libre échange qui consiste à aller
produire à dix mille kilomètres pour
consommer dix mille kilomètres plus loin
est un modèle qui tue la planète j'ai
donc conçu l'intégralité de mon projet
autour du localisme autour de la
relocalisation des productions et des
activités je veux que l'on puisse créer
sur place consommer au plus prêt à tout
il ya des choses qu'on ne pourra pas
fabriqués ou on ne pourra pas cultivé
mais au maximum partir sur la
relocalisation mais ça veut dire aussi
que l'état doit assumer cette
responsabilité et assumer cette
responsabilité se met en place le
patriotisme économique c'est à dire
faire en sorte qu'on arrête par exemple
d'importer la moitié de nos fruits et
légumes alors que nous avons
parfaitement la capacité de pouvoir
répondre à la demande française et c'est
par l'intermédiaire du patriotisme
économique faire en sorte que les
collectivités l'état et notamment dans
la restauration collective s'engage à
acheter pas bio parce que bio il ya du
bio étrangers inquiets parfois
d'ailleurs - dont les normes sont moins
précises et est moins sévère que le bio
français non français voilà que l'on
puisse avoir des produits français dans
les cantines collectives de notre pays
ça c'est essentiel et puis je vous dire
quand on parle environnement est une
chose dont on parle pas souvent c'est la
souffrance animale pourquoi j'en parle
parce que le libre échange est le modèle
de libre échange est un modèle qui
également fait beaucoup de mal aux
animaux parce que lorsque l'on n'accepte
des circuits qui fait que ont fait
naître
et des bêtes en france qu'on va les
transporter dans des camions dans des
conditions qu'ils ont évidemment
éprouvante et douloureuse à des
centaines de kilomètres pour aller les
engraisser puis à nouveau à des
centaines d'euros voire des milliers de
kilomètres pour aller les abattre c'est
un modèle qui est un modèle qui est
insensé qui crée du chômage dans notre
pays qui créent de 2 des émissions de
gueule de gaz à effet de serre de 50% et
qui de surcroît créer de la souffrance
animale et qui désespère en fait nos
agriculteurs qui désespère des
industriels parce qu'ils se retrouvent
confrontés en plus à une concurrence
déloyale car il arrive bien souvent que
ces importations ne respectent pas les
normes que nous sommes choisis comme un
choix de société et donc les
concurrencent directement sur leur
secteur et m'a donc d'abord avant de
parler d'énergie parce que ja oui il
n'ya pas un thème mais avant de parler
d'énergie qui est un élément fondamental
va y venir il y a le modèle économique à
remettre en cause et puis il y a
évidemment des choix énergétiques dont
on a en déjà d'aller et venir mais
d'abord un un peu parlé tout le
parallélisme des questions pour emmanuel
macron même question pour vous quelles
sont les deux engagements vous vous
engagez à tenir la manuelle macron si
vous êtes réélu pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique mais d'abord
qui est intéressant à vous écouter c'est
l'incohérence de notre conversation
parce que quand vous parlez de remettre
en cause le modèle de libre échange et
de nos importations
nos importations qui nous pose le plus
de problèmes et en terme de déficit
commercial que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure et en termes de bilan carbone
c'est notre dépendance aux hydrocarbures
et vous avez proposé la plus grosse
subvention aux hydrocarbures possible
puisque vous baisser la tva sur ces
derniers donc je dis juste que votre
programme le nikon it est cet égard
puisque vous vous proposez une baisse
pérenne comme vous l'avez dit sur les
hydrocarbures énergie fossile très
polluante juste par cohérence fonds
propres et aux îlots chaude bon moi je
considère que là on à sydney sur une
controverse clair lui votre projet est
très transparent vous êtes
climato-sceptiques donc ses dettes oui
vous avez dit d'ailleurs que avec vous
la neutralité carbone 2050 c'est-à-dire
les jalons des accords de paris mais moi
j'ai lu j'ai vu j'ai été frappé une fois
encore par le rapport du giec et j'ai à
la fois un bilan mais je vais aller
beaucoup plus vite on a doublé le rythme
de réduction de gaz à effet de serre
durant ce quinquennat et lancé une
politique pour la biodiversité je veux
aller deux fois plus vite dans le
quinquennat qui vient c'est pourquoi
première chose que je fais c'est que je
mets un premier mini skate en charge de
cette politique et qui sera en charge de
décliner une planification énergétique
d'une part et une planification
territoriale d'autre part pour la
production d énergie mais aussi pour la
transition
ensuite pour moi la deuxième grande
mesure c'est de continuer à accompagner
l'évolution des grands cycles productif
et de mode de vie la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments pour la sobriété
700 mille logements par an qu'on peut
rénover on en a fait 650 milles en 2021
j'en veux 700 mille par an sur les cinq
années qui viennent formidable source
d'économie d'énergie et c'est un levier
aussi de créations d'emplois pour nos
artisans deuxième chose aider nos
compatriotes a changé de véhicule est
allé vers des véhicules hybrides ou
électriques produits en france
nous avons pendant ce quinquennat mais 3
giga factory de batteries électriques
sur notre sol dans la région des hautes
france qui nous est cher et donc
développer cela et puis également
accompagner la transition industrielle
comme la transition agricole pour
pouvoir réduire leurs émissions pas par
injonction par investissements
et le pen tête vous voulez répondre à ce
besoin de dire aimer macron oui j'ai
répondre à ce qu'a dit emmanuel accrue
absolument pas aux sceptiques en aucun
cas mais vous vous êtes un peu klimato
hypocrite d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
pour ça que les gens ne croient pas à
votre volonté de régler tous ces
problèmes là je veux dire pourquoi ils
ont raison d'ailleurs c'est que vous
êtes en même temps le pire de l'écologie
punitive vous avez accompagné des choses
qui sont d'une grande violence pour les
classes moyennes pour les classes
modestes de nos compatriotes toutes les
décisions qui ont été prises qui
consiste à expliquer aux gens qui sont
coupables parce qu'il s'achète pas une
voiture électrique même s'ils n'ont pas
les moyens de le faire parce que le
reste à charge mais bien sûr
est
extrêmement important toutes les mesures
que vous voulez prendre leur disant vous
n'aurez plus droit de réparer votre
chaudière à fuel vous n'aurez pas le
droit de la changer alors qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens évidemment de même avec
l'aide de l'état de faire autrement les
zones à faible émission c'est à dire
l'interdiction qui va être fait et qui
est déjà fait d'ailleurs en partie aux
gens qui ont des voitures anciennes de
pouvoir aller dans les grandes villes y
compris d'ailleurs s'il ya un hôpital
dans cette grande ville où ils doivent
se rendre ils ne pourront plus s'y
rendre tous à 7,7 écologie punitive elle
est inutile elle crée des encore une
fois des souffrances elle aggrave des
situations qui sont des situations de
fragilité d'ores et déjà parce que ça
tombe toujours sur les mêmes c'est
toujours sur ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens vous le savez bien ceux qui ont
les moyens n'ont pas ce genre de
problème donc ça moi je suis je suis
profondément en désaccord avec cela oui
à la transition bien sûr il faut qu'il y
ait une transition mais il faut qu'elle
soit évidemment dans le temps beaucoup
moins rapide que ce qu'on impose aux
français pour permettre pour leur
permettre de pouvoir de pouvoir y faire
face ça c'est une c'est une évidence et
puis la deuxième des choses c'est vos
changements de pied quand même vous avez
sur l'énergie qui est pourtant un
élément structurant quand même de
l'avenir d'un pays l'énergie et
notamment l'indépendance et le choix
d'une énergie décarbonée qu'est le
nucléaire vous avez complètement changé
d'avis vous avez démarré votre mandat on
explique en enfermant fessenheim en
fermant fessenheim alors qu'aucune
justification de sécurité ne le
permettaient tout le monde et toutes les
structures disait que en termes de
sûreté de sécurité avait aucune
difficulté avec le sable vous l'avez
fermé vous avez envisagé de fermer 14
réacteurs nucléaires vous avez arrêté
astrid et puis à la fin de votre mandat
vous dit bien je me suis trompé bah oui
vous êtes peut-être trompé mais le
problème c'est que vous étiez aussi
trompé quand vous étiez avec aux côtés
de françois hollande ça fait qu'on a
perdu 10 ans à déstabiliser une filière
nucléaire qui avait besoin d'être
renforcé il y avait besoin d'être
soutenus qu'ils avaient besoin de
visibilité dans l'avenir pour pouvoir
faire de cet outil décarbonés et qui
nous permet d'être indépendant à nouveau
un socle pour notre mix énergétique
c'est extrêmement regrettable vous avez
fait le choix par ailleurs d éolien de
l'éolienne pardon et du solaire l'éolien
étant le pire
et puisque il est en même temps une
absurdité écologique une absurdité
économique une une gêne fondamental pour
la biodiversité une un soin qui fait
baisser le prix des biens immobiliers
qui sont à proximité enfin qui est
alternative donc elle fonctionne
évidemment quand il ya du vent mais pas
devant elle fonctionne pas et quand
elles ne fonctionnent pas et vient le
fait fonctionner des centrales à gaz ou
à charbon je veux te voir compenser donc
vous avez vous n'aviez pas de vision
dans ce domaine et je crois que vous
avez mis la france en grande difficulté
marie saubanère vous avez sur ce thème
là d'énergie qui nous intéresse tous
beaucoup de trois minutes d'avancé
emmanuel macron marine le pen ne
mentionnait il ya un instant à la fin
des fins vous êtes plutôt d'accord sur
la politique concernant le l'énergie
nucléaire grande différence en revanche
concernant les éoliennes dans son
programme marine le pen volet veulent et
démentent et ne pas en construire de 9
vous vous êtes plutôt en faveur des
éoliennes surtout les éoliennes en mer
c'est cela oui
d'abord pas un mot sur l'écologie dans
122 mesures pour la france il ya un
livret et le livret d'ailleurs qui est
qui est assez édifiant donc je vais y
revenir parce que il dit très clairement
ce que ce que j'évoquais à l'instant
d'abord quand j'ai été ministre de
l'économie des finances je peux pas vous
laisser dire que vous avez dit puisque
je me suis occupé de la restructuration
du secteur nucléaire qui était en train
de s'effondrer et je pense à tous les
goûts tous les salariés tous les
ouvriers de ce secteur à tous les
savoir-faire qu'on a on l'a sauvée grâce
au vaisseau amiral edf qui a fait un
travail formidable et aussi la
restructuration qu'on a qu'on a réussi à
faire à ce moment-là ensuite fessenheim
j'assume totalement madame le pen y'a et
puis un investissement depuis 2002
c'était la plus vieille en cirque qui
étaient en service et il n'y avait plus
d'investissements depuis 2012 et donc
quand on voit les difficultés qu'on a
sur le parc installé avec les
investissements que j'ai décidé dès le
début du quinquennat de grand carénage
la rentabilité de ce projet n'était plus
du tout au rendez vous et donc il était
devenu pertinent d'aller au bout une
aide compenser le territoire et la
transition j'assume d'avoir fermé et on
a réussi en quasi totalité le retard sur
le père de flamanville nous a pas permis
de le faire en totalité nos centrales
thermiques nous en avions fallait
prendre la décision fallait le courage
d'aller expliquer aux gens
et d'est en ouest de saint-avold au
havre ailleurs nous l'avons fait parce
que nous avons fait cette transition
pour justement - et m donc on a une j'ai
lu pendant ces cinq ans une vraie
stratégie vraie volonté et j'ai reposé
dès 2018 le sujet de la baisse du
nucléaire qui avait été votée en 2015
j'ai reposé en demandant l agence
internationale de l'énergie aie à rte de
me faire une analyse quand elle m'a été
rendue je les ai suivis ils disent très
clairement d'abord que le programme qui
est le vôtre est intenable puisque vous
un jour envoie ce rapport d'experts et
d'ailleurs ça correspond à ce que tous
les experts indépendants et compris du
giec est d'ailleurs 10 il n'y a pas de
stratégie de sortie des énergies
fossiles qui me passe par le tout
nucléaire votre stratégie d'une
stratégie du tout nucléaire elle n'est
pas possible et vous ne pouvez pas
remplacés y compris le renouvelable
actuelle que vous voulez démonter par du
nucléaire car le nucléaire qu'on décide
aujourd'hui il entrera en service en
2035 madame le pen donc le temps il
connaît pas ne nous ne nous rend pas
dans une situation peu remplacer l'un
par l'autre il faut faire les deux là
aussi pardon de la référence aux auteurs
en même temps c'est d'ailleurs
exactement la conclusion de ce rapport
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé à la lumière
de ce rapport un programme de nouvelles
tranches de pair
6 puis vite mais surtout d'investir dans
le renouvelable
de se donner plus de temps sur l'éolien
terrestre pour ça que j'ai divisé par
deux le rythme par rapport à ce qui
était prévu initialement pour le donner
à 2050 comme horizon mais de développer
le solaire le petit solaire dans nos
ruralité c'est demander la grille volta
isme est un vrai projet qui veulent
porter nos agriculteurs si les raisonner
et on va le faire avec eux est ce qu'on
veut aussi faire c'est de l'éolien en
mer pourquoi parce que ça crée de
l'emploi vautrot j'ai en effet proposé
vous de stopper mais de les démonter
vous allez démanteler les éoliennes qui
existe ce qui coûte un argent fou et
donc je trouve que l'argent du
contribuable pour être mieux utilisé ce
d'autant que dans toutes ces filières
nous créons de l'emploi en france quand
on fait de l'éolien en mer ont créé de
l'emploi j'étais au havre dans une usine
la semaine dernière où en france nous
produisons les pales
l'ensemble des infrastructures pour ces
éoliennes en mer kovac ainsi qu'on va
ainsi développer faut concerter avec les
pêcheurs avec l'ensemble des usages ce
qu'on fait faut aller plus vite sur nos
projets mais faut pouvoir le développer
le seul moyen de répondre au défi
climatique c'est de faire les énergies
renouvelables et du nucléaire il faut
faire les deux simplement faut pas
refaire les erreurs du passé il faut
pouvoir développer des filières
industrielles dans notre pays comme j'ai
commencé à le faire durant ces cinq
années de la batterie électrique
jusqu'aux éoliennes et comme je veux
continuer de le faire bien on vous
mettra pas d'accord sur cette question
là non je vous laisse répondre à l avais
un peu oui mais rapidement juste
parce que on quand j'entends parler
concertation que les pêcheurs moi je les
ai tous rencontrés ils sont tous vents
debout évidemment que je les fais
de la peine de leurs 3000 je crois vous
voulez en mettre partout sur toutes les
côtes sauf en face du touquet parce
qu'il faut quand même pas non plus
madame le pen ou c mais je tiens à le
dire et à dire à ceux qui nous écoutent
que le dogme c'est la réalité
tous deux ont été actés sauf celui en
face du touquet même jour mais vous
rigolez démantèlement des
démantèlements la planification pas
comme on a déjà subi à 50 qui sont déjà
mais
le démantèlement des éoliennes eco ce
moment de leur installation au prénom
c'est le hasard
on est passé du free a pendant mon
mandat j'ai toujours dit jallet engagé
le chantier du démantèlement j'ai engagé
chantilly éventuellement déjà y en a
deux mille qui vont arriver en bout de
course et en bout de course et bien ce
n'est pas l'état qui paye le
démantèlement se sont davantage de sens
mais c'est l'exploitant qui démantèlent
et c'est cautionner et vous le savez
très bien cautionner auprès de la caisse
des dépôts en revanche que je
démantèlerait c'est ceux des éoliennes
qui représente 1 troubles anormaux du
voisinage et il y en a de plus en plus
et bout de plus en plus d'ailleurs de
tribunaux qui constatent ces troubles
anormaux du voisinage eh bien on
commencera par celle là et puis on fera
des référendum on demandera l'avis aux
gens je sais que vous n'aimez pas bien
ça mais moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup sa
demande sur ce sujet dont on se distrait
pour leur demander s'ils souhaitent et
aimante et on va engager ce chantier là
parce que encore une fois ça coûte très
cher aux français ça pollue nos paysages
cet intermittent on s'appuie sur du gaz
et du charbon et ça n'est vraiment pas
la bonne solution alors que nous avons
l'hydroélectricité sur lequel nous
pouvons évidemment nous appuie dans
notre mix énergétique et nous aurons
besoin de plus en plus de l'hydrogène
vert que d'ailleurs je
je m'appelle on le fait comment
l'hydrogène vert avec du nucléaire donc
l'hydrogène arrière comme vous allait
supprimer 15 sociétés dans l'âme on le
fait on a négocié la france est battue
votre serviteur nuit avec les avions
conclu avec du nucléaire à venir parce
qu'aujourd'hui notre nucléaire n'est pas
pour fait il n'est pas fait pour faire
l'hydrogène il est fait pour nous
chauffer donc vous avec votre stratégie
vous ne pourrez pas faire dit -
d'hydrogène non mais vous mais moi j'ai
un plan pour développer le nucléaire
mais vous n'arriverez pas à 35 madame
lopez début de mon mandat et vous avez
le temps industriel madame le pen
donc vous ne verrez pas produit et savez
moi je ne suis pas comme vous non je ne
ferme pas fait c'est vrai je ne ferme en
sachant je vous remercie de sa risque
que ça risque de poser des problèmes de
production voyez
j'engagerai le chantier en fonction et
notamment en attendant que flamanville
soit mis en
fonctionnement et à ce moment là on
démarrera ce chantier des attentes je
crois les français l'hydrogène n'est pas
une source d'énergie oui j'ai bien
compris merci non mais je vous le dis
parce que donc et parler du mix
énergétique non mais donc c'est pas une
source d'énergie pour faire de
l'hydrogène en particulier vers ou peu
polluants parce que les terminologies
devant avec les nucléaire il faut ou du
nucléaire nous nous sommes battus pour
l'obtenir ou du renouvelable bon si vous
vous stoppez le renouvelable on va
produire moins d'électricité
de fait et donc alors même qu'on a des
besoins aujourd'hui vous ne m'explique
pas comment on va faire face pour nous
passer de l'hydrocarbure pour baisser
notre dépendance au gaz russe aux
énergies fossiles puisque vous vous
détruisez pendant des années des
capacités à produire de l'électricité
avec la bière que je les aurai de
manière progressive en fonction de votre
nouveau nucléaire il ne commencera pas
avant 2035 j'ai décidé si tranche à
belfort elles ouvriront en 2035 aux
dires mêmes de df aller que vers herat
en 2023 un petit peu dur de bf je suis
prudent je ne suis pas le thé marine le
pen mais ça c'est déjà dans nos chiffres
naïf à mettre sur la touche
stratégie elle ne boucle manuel macron
si elle boucle la boucle par emmanuel et
d'ailleurs et aucun groupe et marine le
pen est appuyée sur une vision
c'est une vision madame
élevé
[Musique]